Transcription: Charlotte Le Guen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Beaucoup de phénomènes
qui se dévoilent à nous
ne sont, en réalité, que le reflet
d'une multitude d'événements complexes
qui se jouent en arrière-plan
et échappent à notre perception naturelle.
Les illusionnistes manient ceci
avec talent,
détournant notre regard
pour nous cacher la vérité
et nous donner l'illusion
de phénomènes impossibles.
Qui n'a jamais rêvé de percer
les secrets de ces tours de magie
qui émerveillent les petits
et interrogent les grands ?
Pour moi, en tant que scientifique,
je dois vous dire
que c'est presque obsessionnel
et que comprendre ces tours de magie
prend souvent le pas sur l'émerveillement
du tour en lui-même.
Découvrir le secret de ces illusions
nécessite, généralement,
de changer de point de vue
pour découvrir ce qui nous était,
jusqu'alors, invisible.
Je vous invite à ouvrir les yeux,
à changer de perspective
pour sortir de votre zone de perception
et découvrir ainsi un monde invisible
qui évolue juste sous vos yeux
dans nos parcs, nos jardins et nos forêts.
En quelque sorte, à voir l'invisible
et tout ça pour comprendre
le monde qui nous entoure.
Si vous vous promenez en forêt,
peut-être avez-vous déjà observé
d'étranges structures
à la surface des feuilles, sur les tiges
ou sur les bourgeons.
Parfois plates, parfois rondes,
parfois colorées, parfois poilues,
ces structures et leur diversité
fascinent et interrogent les biologistes
depuis des siècles.
Ces structures végétales,
c'est ce qu'on appelle des galles.
Des sortes de prolifération des cellules
de la plante, comme des tumeurs.
Ces galles, ces structures végétales,
n'apparaissent pas comme ça par hasard.
Elles sont la conséquence de la présence,
à l'intérieur du végétal,
de petits insectes
qui prennent littéralement le contrôle
de la machinerie cellulaire de la plante
pour créer de véritables nouveaux organes.
Avec, parfois, des structures
complètement extravagantes
comme ces galles chevelues
que l'on peut observer
sur les rosiers ou sur les églantiers.
Lorsque je dis que je travaille
sur ces insectes,
qui vivent dans les végétaux,
qui en prennent le contrôle,
qui les manipulent,
on me pose généralement la question :
« Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
à travailler avec des insectes ? »
J'aimerais vous répondre que,
tout petit, je ramassais des coccinelles,
que j'ai chez moi une collection
d'insectes rares
ou que je passe mes week-ends à quatre
pattes à observer les petites bêtes.
En réalité, pas du tout.
Si j'en suis venu à travailler avec
les insectes, c'est un peu par hasard,
au cours de mes études.
Avec le temps, on se prend d'affection
pour ces organismes.
Je dois dire que les insectes présentent
des particularités extraordinaires.
Ce qui est bien plus au cœur
de mon activité scientifique,
ce n'est pas tant les insectes,
mais c'est finalement comprendre le monde,
dévoiler les secrets de son fonctionnement
et révéler, au monde,
une réalité invisible.
Si ça, ce n'est pas un objectif de vie :
« Révéler au monde
une réalité invisible. »
Je vous le disais, le scientifique
a un besoin de comprendre.
Pour comprendre, on se pose, généralement,
deux grands types de questions :
le « Pourquoi ? » -
à quoi ça sert ? -
et le « Comment ? » -
Comment ça marche ?
Moi, je suis plutôt du style comment.
Pourquoi ces structures,
à quoi elles servent ?
Pendant très longtemps,
on a adopté le point de vue de la plante
et on a considéré que c'était
un mécanisme de défense
qui permettait à la plante
d'emprisonner l'insecte,
et donc, de protéger la plante
contre des dommages trop importants.
Ce n'est qu'à partir du moment
où on a pris le point de vue de l'insecte
qu'on a réellement révélé
la fonction de ces structures.
En réalité, en créant ces structures,
l'insecte va créer un environnement
dans lequel il va être protégé
des prédateurs, des maladies,
des perturbations environnementales
- la pluie, le vent -
mais également un environnement
nutritif extrêmement favorable.
La plante fournit donc
le gîte et le couvert.
Maintenant, comprendre le comment
nécessite de déceler les mécanismes
qui vont aboutir à la production
de ces galles.
En science, on a une manière
de répondre à ces questions
qui consiste à faire des comparaisons.
On peut, par exemple, comparer
une plante attaquée avec une plante saine.
On peut faire ces comparaisons
au niveau biochimique,
au niveau physiologique,
au niveau morphologique
ou au niveau des gènes.
On peut, par exemple, comparer les gènes
qui sont exprimés dans un bourgeon intact
ou dans un bourgeon attaqué par un insecte
qui va se transformer en galle.
Lorsqu'on fait ceci, on se rend compte,
que les gènes qui sont impliqués
dans la production des galles,
ressemblent de très près
aux gènes qui sont impliqués
dans la production des fruits.
A y regarder d'un peu plus près,
la structure et la morphologie des galles
ressemblent très fréquemment
à la morphologie des fruits.
Sachant ceci, voyons donc
si vous commencez à observer le monde
sous un angle différent.
Si je vous montre cette photo,
qui d'entre vous pense
que ceci est un fruit ?
Levez la main.
Je dois avouer que ce n'est pas le fruit
qu'on voit le plus dans les supermarchés
ou sur les étalages.
Mais c'est effectivement un fruit.
Certaines galles présentent
des structures extrêmement similaires.
Une petite chance de vous rattraper,
si je vous montre cette figue, désormais.
Qui, d'entre vous,
pense que ceci est un fruit ?
Levez la main.
Cette fois-ci, on a plus de monde !
En fait, il y avait un peu un piège.
C'est à la fois une galle et un fruit.
Entre nous, appelons ça un « gallifruit ».
Comme ça, ce sera plus simple.
En réalité, les figues, ce sont
des petits sacs charnus
qui renferment une multitude,
des milliers de petites fleurs.
Celles-ci vont être fertilisées
grâce à l'intervention de petits insectes
qui vont entrer, à l'intérieur,
chargés de pollen.
Ils vont donc fertiliser certaines fleurs
qui vont se développer en fruit
mais vont également pondre
dans d'autres fleurs
et les larves vont former
des petites galles
dont elles vont se nourrir.
Lorsque vous mangez une figue,
vous mangez donc une multitude
de petits fruits mais, également,
une multitude de bébés guêpes.
(Rires)
Je vous le disais, découvrir l'invisible,
c'est changer de perspective.
C'est aussi saisir le moment opportun
de l'observation.
L'automne est un moment privilégié
pour révéler la présence,
au sein du végétal,
de petits insectes qui se développent
en créant des galeries -
on appelle ça des insectes mineurs -
et qui, là encore, vont prendre
le contrôle de la plante
et manipuler le végétal.
Il faut voir, en quelque sorte, l'automne
comme une course contre la montre.
Les arbres vont essayer de récupérer
l'essentiel des éléments nutritifs
qui sont dans les feuilles,
les stocker dans les racines,
pour les réinvestir au printemps suivant
et former de nouvelles feuilles.
C'est ce qui aboutit, entre autres,
au jaunissement des feuilles
puis à la chute des feuilles.
L'insecte, de son côté, va devoir essayer
de compléter son cycle de développement
avant la disparition
de toutes ses ressources nutritives.
Donc, prendre le contrôle de la plante
permet à certains insectes de maintenir
un environnement nutritif favorable
de manière à finir
leur cycle de développement.
C'est pourquoi ces petits insectes
arrivent à maintenir des zones
complètement vertes fonctionnelles
alors que le reste de la feuille jaunit.
En quelque sorte, ils empêchent
la feuille de vieillir.
De là à dire que c'est le secret
de la jeunesse éternelle,
ça reste encore à démontrer.
Ici encore, on peut se poser la question :
« Comment ça marche ? ».
Depuis plus de 50 ans,
à l'institut de recherche
sur la biologie de l'insecte,
on s'interroge sur ces interactions
entre les plantes et les insectes.
Depuis environ une dizaine d'années,
dans mon groupe,
on s'intéresse plus particulièrement
à ces insectes qui manipulent le végétal.
Ça m'amène à une deuxième question
qu'on me pose généralement,
avec un air un peu perplexe :
« Ça fait 10 ans que tu travailles
sur la même chenille ? »
Eh bien oui, ça fait 10 ans
que je travaille sur la même chenille
et je dois vous dire
qu'on est loin d'avoir tout découvert !
Toujours est-il que, même principe,
si on veut comprendre ici
comment l'insecte manipule le végétal
pour créer un environnement
protégé des prédateurs,
des perturbations environnementales
et le tout avec tout ce qu'il faut
pour manger,
on peut procéder à des comparaisons.
Par exemple, comparer une feuille attaquée
avec une feuille saine.
On peut faire ça au niveau de la feuille
ou au niveau de la zone spécifique
où se trouve l'insecte.
Si on fait cette fois-ci cette comparaison
non au niveau des gènes
mais au niveau de la chimie de la feuille,
on peut alors se rendre compte
que si l'insecte est capable de créer
et de maintenir
cette zone verte fonctionnelle,
c'est grâce à l'accumulation
de composés spécifiques
dans la zone où se trouve l'insecte.
Ces composés, ce sont
des hormones végétales
et, plus exactement, des cytokinines.
Je vous le disais,
ce sont des hormones végétales.
La question suivante
qui s'est posée à nous, c'est :
« S'il y a plus de ces hormones
dans la zone où se trouve l'insecte,
d'où viennent-elles ? »
Vous me direz : « Facile, ce sont
des hormones végétales,
c'est la plante qui les produit. »
C'était notre première hypothèse,
effectivement.
Après de multiples études,
on s'est rendu compte que non,
ce n'était pas la plante
qui produisait ces composés.
Donc, si ce n'est pas la plante,
qui est-ce ?
C'est forcément l'insecte ?
Ça ne peut être que l'insecte !
C'est là que je dois vous faire
un terrible aveu.
Et si je ne vous avais pas tout dit ?
Et si, finalement,
tout ceci n'était que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg ?
Et si, finalement, ce n'était pas
l'insecte qui était à la manœuvre
pour manipuler ce végétal ?
En réalité, après de multiples études,
nous avons pu démontrer
que si l'insecte réussit
ce tour de passe-passe
qui empêche la feuille de vieillir,
c'est grâce à la présence,
à l'intérieur même de l'insecte,
de bactéries
qui vivent à l'intérieur
des cellules de l'insecte :
des bactéries symbiotiques.
Pour tester cette hypothèse un peu folle,
nous sommes partis dans des expériences
non moins extravagantes.
Nous avons décidé de nourrir les insectes
avec des antibiotiques.
Ceci nous permet d'obtenir
d'un côté des insectes avec des bactéries
et de l'autre, des insectes
sans bactéries.
Lorsque l'on fait ceci, on se rend compte
qu'en absence de leur passager invisible,
les insectes sont incapables
de manipuler le végétal.
Alors là, ça a été un moment important.
Un de ces moments rares
dans la vie d'un chercheur
où, après de multiples années
de recherches,
fruit du travail d'une équipe entière,
on met le doigt sur les mécanismes
d'un phénomène jusqu'alors inexpliqué.
Ça ne vous parlera peut-être pas,
mais je me souviens encore de l'émotion
que nous avons ressentie
lorsque nous avons fait cette découverte.
On se sentait un peu
comme des explorateurs
ayant découvert des territoires inconnus.
Alors, vous me direz :
« En quoi ceci est si important ? »
Lorsqu'on regarde d'un peu plus près,
la plupart des insectes
vivent en association
avec des micro-organismes,
des bactéries, des virus,
des protozoaires.
Et ces passagers invisibles jouent
des rôles importants dans la physiologie
et, parfois même, dans le comportement
de ces insectes.
Les insectes mais également
de nombreux autres organismes
sont donc à considérer
non pas comme des entités uniques
mais comme la juxtaposition
d'un ensemble d'organismes
qui vivent ensemble.
En plus ou moins bonne harmonie.
Les développements technologiques
de ces dernières années
nous ont permis des avancées considérables
dans l'identification
et la caractérisation
de cette communauté invisible
qui est hébergée
par la plupart des organismes.
Je suis persuadé que ceci nous permettra
des avancées considérables
dans la compréhension du monde
qui nous entoure.
Les conséquences
de cet assemblage d'organismes,
de tous ces micro-organismes
qui vivent au sein des êtres vivants
sont considérables.
Nous avons des implications
en termes de santé humaine,
en termes agronomiques,
en termes de conservation.
Pour vous donner quelques exemples :
la plupart des insectes
vivent avec des micro-organismes.
C'est également le cas des plantes.
Certaines plantes cultivées, notamment,
ont, au niveau des racines,
des bactéries ou des champignons
qui vont leur permettre d'assimiler mieux
les éléments nutritifs du sol
et donc une meilleure croissance.
Si on comprend le rôle
de ces micro-organismes,
à l'heure où on essaie de développer
une agriculture écologiquement responsable
on peut finalement inoculer délibérément
ces micro-organismes dans les cultures
et augmenter la productivité agricole
simplement en stimulant
des procédés naturels.
Un autre exemple peut-être
un peu plus proche de vous.
On sait, aujourd'hui, que de nombreux
micro-organismes sont responsables
de pathologies ou de dysfonctionnements
majeurs comme par exemple l'obésité.
Ici encore, comprendre comment
interviennent ces micro-organismes
pourrait permettre des alternatives
aux traitements médicamenteux.
Aujourd'hui, on fait des transplantations
entre patients de micro-organismes
qui nous permettent de résoudre
une partie de ces dysfonctionnements.
Enfin, en termes de conservation,
on a des écosystèmes spectaculaires,
comme par exemple les récifs coralliens,
où il y a des associations étroites
avec des algues colorées.
Les grandes perturbations,
telles que le réchauffement des océans,
entraînent la perte de ces algues
et une fragilisation des coraux
qui finissent par mourir.
C'est le blanchissement
des récifs coralliens.
Ici encore, comprendre le rôle
des micro-organismes,
identifier peut-être certains
qui auraient une tolérance,
une résistante plus importante
aux variations de températures,
pourrait peut-être permettre de préserver
ces écosystèmes si particuliers
et tous les rôles qu'ils remplissent
en termes de nutrition,
en termes de protection des zones côtières
ou, tout simplement,
en termes touristiques.
La biodiversité,
notre patrimoine naturel,
est donc à concevoir, désormais,
dans sa globalité
avec sa part visible
mais également avec sa part invisible.
Et c'est par la compréhension
de ces passagers invisibles
et de leur fonction dans les écosystèmes
que passent peut-être nos espoirs
de conservation et de valorisation
de notre patrimoine naturel.
C'est un enjeu considérable.
C'est un véritable défi
pour les scientifiques,
mais c'est également un devoir
si nous voulons développer une société
en harmonie avec son environnement.
En préambule,
je vous invitais à ouvrir les yeux
sur le monde qui nous entoure,
à changer de perspective.
J'espère que vous marcherez, désormais,
les yeux grand ouverts
pour percevoir cette part invisible
de notre environnement.
Et je suis persuadé
que vous découvrirez les insectes
et que vous les regarderez désormais
avec un angle nouveau
en ayant conscience qu'ils hébergent,
en leur sein,
toute une communauté invisible.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)